Some say it contains, this is about as many as there are stars in the Milky Way.
Others say it probably has more than a hundred billion.
To end, the neurons of the human brain equal the distance of the earth to the moon.
The human brain developed approximately three billion years ago.
There were algae, then bacteria, then invertebrates, then fish, reptiles.
Two hundred million years ago, the primitive brain of the great reptile enabled them to survive through primitive responses alone.
For example, rest of defense of their territory.
Responses such as these also exist in modern man.
Approximately a hundred million years ago, the paleocortex developed,
incorporating emotions such as apprehension, fear, and the beginning of memory.
In a situation of danger, the instinct for survival is demonstrated.
Approximately a hundred thousand years ago, the neocortex developed.
Represents 85% of the cerebral mass of the human brain.
Now the interpretation of ideas is made possible.
Club equals food and hide and bones.
It is therefore the neocortex which enables man to think and reason, behave in a civilized manner.
The reptilian brain, the paleocortex or primitive mammalian brain, and the neocortex or modern man's brain.
Unfortunately, communication between them is not always perfect.
Ah! Don't you look where you're going, you idiot!
You're not gonna let him get away with that, are you? Huh?
Is there anything wrong here?
Well then, move on.
Before we're approaching the brain, now you'll be able to see how this remarkable organ functions.
It contains billions of neurons, with billions and billions of synaptic connections.
You'll see it's extraordinary.
Possibly be of help, Professor, if the brain is such a perfect organ.
Oxygen really so important to it?
Yes, very important, Globin.
The brain's needs are really enormous.
It uses 2,000 liters of blood a day, which provides 60 liters of air.
This is 20% of the body's oxygen requirements.
Without us, if the brain were deprived of the oxygen we supply,
fainting and then loss of consciousness would occur.
If the supply was cut off, say, a few minutes,
the brain would suffer irreparable damage and the whole organism would simply die.
Is anything wrong, Professor?
Have you lost your way? Oh, we'd better move.
Move along, move along. Please keep moving.
It's not the place to stop and have a chat.
There, gramps.
Oh, heavens, what a day and age.
There's no respect for the elderly.
My day, children were seen and not heard.
You carry some of your oxygen bubbles, my pretty globin.
Accelerate the blood circulation immediately.
I repeat, accelerate the blood circulation immediately.
Please respond to an urgent request from the heart.
Oh, Professor, aren't you coming with us?
Children, you see, we are independent of the rest of the body.
What happens elsewhere doesn't concern us.
If it has to do with the heart.
Oh no, the brain doesn't obey, it commands.
It has absolute priority, Globin, even over the heart.
Oh no, no, to you lot.
That passage over there.
But why are you coming with us?
Because oxygen is what the brain needs most.
And also sugar.
But they have to take special passageways assigned to them.
We'd be near enough to the neurons to give them oxygen.
Never, my dear.
Neurons are too sensitive to come into direct contact with us.
It works rather differently, you'll see.
Jumbo, hurry!
Inside the dendrite nerve end, a little messenger is waiting to relay the message along the axon.
It's easy. Right, we'll transmit that message.
It's up into numerous nerve ends.
Nerve cell has 100,000 synaptic connections.
And as we know, the brain has 10 billion nerve cells.
Imagine how many synaptic connections there are if these two figures are multiplied.
Little chemical messengers now arrive at the nucleus of the neuron.
Pass on their messages to be processed.
So, what are they asking for?
Um, Jumbo is thirsty, sir.
Terribly hot.
Shall we ask for the breathing to be accelerated, sir, do you think?
And also for a rising temperature, sir.
We'll send messages to the heart, the lungs and the diaphragm.
Isn't that right, sir?
Have you finished showing off?
Your job is to transmit to the medulla oblongata, is that clear?
It will decide the rest.
Get going now, all of you.
Move.
Cortical zone R12.
Faster pulse rate.
Iron permeability insufficient in sector 2083.
Sending messengers.
He's thirsty, sir. What shall I do?
Transmit to the hypothalamus that it must order Jumbo to drink.
Don't waste time doing that. It's not that urgent.
Now look here. We've already made the temperature rise.
And also ask for perspiration.
And the acceleration of the breathing.
But I still say we must transmit the order to drink.
No, we must first ask the heart to beat faster.
And the lungs to breathe harder and the thermoregulation center...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We cannot ask for everything all at once.
We must get our priorities right.
Oh, you old fool.
You're the old fool.
That idiot.
Now wait, huh?
We'll transmit everything to the forebrain and it will make the right decisions.
Brother, good lord.
What about our responsibility?
It's really at least 1,000 times faster than we do.
Yes, but that's only the transmission of the orders.
Each order relies on previous knowledge, memory, experience, and reason.
How does the brain manage to know so much?
That globin is the great mystery of the brain.
Quantity of data that it is capable of storing defies imagination.
Please tell us more, Professor.
Hmm, well, let me see. Hmm.
Move along there, please. Hurry up.
Well, well, the brain receives information from all the senses and all the organs as well.
It then distributes the information among its neurons, or nerve cells, if you prefer.
It's thought to happen more or less as follows.
We must register that a thorn pricks.
Register that the prick of a thorn hurts.
A thorn prick causes a wound that bleeds.
Please commence manufacture of proteins for the storage of this information.
Now, where are those proteins?
We must hurry. The information to be stored is arriving.
This way for the pain, please. Straight ahead for the blood.
Blood is red, this way please.
Blood is sticky, this way please.
Blood stains, this way please.
Blood is warm, this way please.
Hot, hot, quite simple.
No, Globin is not that simple at all.
Because when a thorn pricks you, it isn't just the few messengers I mentioned to you
that carry the necessary information to the brain for storage.
Thousands upon thousands, each one carries a different message.
Information about this drop of blood will be filed under a great many headings,
such as smell, taste, temperature and composition.
Register that it smells good.
Register that a rose is soft.
Mmm.
Register that a rose is beautiful, sir.
Register that a rose is as light as a feather.
Register that a rose is fragile.
Thorns can hurt. Register that.
Rose is pink.
No!
What?
Red!
A rose is pink!
A rose is white!
No, a rose is yellow!
No, I'm telling you, a rose is pink!
Stop! Stop! That's enough now! Stop arguing! In fact, you're all correct.
Because roses can be all those colours and more.
Colours she saw must be registered, so get a move on.
But, Professor, how does the brain manage to store all that information and what happens to it?
Oh dear, you have not been paying attention, young Globus.
When, for example, the eye receives information or perceives danger,
it sends this message to the brain, which draws on its stored knowledge
and orders the necessary action to be taken.
Transmit that she must be very careful.
Thorns prick. There's a risk he might lose his balance.
Oh, I don't think we need to worry about that, sir.
Surely he will react by reflex straight from the spinal cord.
Let's not take any chances, shall we?
Transmit to the regions concerned.
Bellum control room.
There's a risk of loss of balance.
Automatic regulation through reflex action.
Activate automatic regulation.
Inform the cortex to take emergency measures.
This is the cortex control room.
Order left leg to move forward quickly to help regain balance.
Instruct the hypothalamus to order the adrenal glands to pump adrenaline.
As a precaution, bring the arms forward in order to absorb the shock if he should fall.
Knows mainly those things we consciously inform it of.
For the rest, it stores only about one hundredth of what we unconsciously perceive,
because the brain receives all the information at the same time.
Noise, shape, colour, touch, feelings, association of ideas.
It stores the most important information.
But which part of the brain gives orders, Professor?
Well, each part of the body is controlled by a specific area of the brain.
A larger area is required by the more sensitive parts of the body.
For example, the face and the hands.
Tell me, sir, does the brain have total control of the individual?
Oh, well, that's more or less right.
But the communication between the different parts of the brain isn't always perfect.
You see, the most primitive part always tries to dominate.
These two out.
Just listen to that healthy cough.
Pulse, increase the blood pressure, make more sugar, get ready to attack.
It's all worked up about such a trivial matter.
Slow the heart down, get rid of the extra sugar.
Why doesn't he mind his own business?
Control here!
Brain contains a hundred thousand million cells.
Billion, billion, billion, billion, billion connections.
It is capable of a million reactions per minute.
To write the number of possible connections, you'd need a figure with ten million kilometers of noughts.
Or 26 times the distance between the Earth and the Moon.
And that ends our story of the brain, the most fascinating organ in the universe.